Hello, Los Angeles.
Emirates welcomes you to Dodger Stadium.
This stadium has 10 gates, 21 terraced entrances and can hold over 56,000 fans.
Today's game between the Cincinnati Reds and the Los Angeles Dodgers...
...will consist of nine innings,...
...and like our nonstop flight from Los Angeles to Dubai,...
...we recommend you stretch during the seventh inning.
Keep your eye on the ball in the event of a foul ball or home run.
If you see coaches or umpires acting in a strange way,...
...do not attempt to intervene...
...as our expert staff are trained for just such emergencies.
In the event of turbulent times during the game,...
...your hat can act as a rally cap.
To activate, turn your hat inside out and place directly on your head.
Remember to always secure your rally cap first before assisting others.